si claramente nos tenemos que remitirnos
a
1833 que cuando una embarcación
tripulada por británicos desalojó a
digamos las instalaciones y al personal
bonaerense para llamarlo con más
propiedad porque en 1833 la república
argentina no estaba conformada como tal
digamos el proceso de organización del
estado nacional argentino y la
confederación de provincias que le dan
base data recién de tres décadas después
en la década de 1860
fue sin lugar a dudas un acto colonial
como se dirimían en aquel entonces las
cuestiones geopolíticas y territoriales
siempre ponen potencias y también entre
las jóvenes naciones de las periferias
sudamericanas que habían protagonizado
las revoluciones de independencia por
supuesto con este punto de toda una
serie de matices y de complejidades
digamos
malvinas y este es un tema muy sentido
para la población argentina donde años
de escolaridad han insistido en la
definición de que las islas malvinas son
argentinas ahora eso merece a 40 años de
la derrota de la guerra ser pensado con
mayor profundidad cuál es la legitimidad
la legalidad de esos papeles y en qué
medida eso se puede contrastar también
con otras visiones y con otras
perspectivas históricas de la misma
problemática
insisto en este punto la argentina no
existía como tal en 1833 lo que había
era provincias
con el paso de la fecha conformaron una
confederación entonces así como está el
argumento argentino en pos de esta
legitimidad también está el argumento
británico y diría más que británico el
argumento de la propia población de
origen británico de las islas es un
factor frecuentemente desatendido ha
medido a menudo como son pocos digamos
pocos entre comillas una población
estable de 3.000 personas se desconocen
sus derechos y este es un factor
importante a tener en cuenta porque se
trata en algunos casos de personas que
registran 9 generaciones de presencia en
la cinta bueno mire hablando sobre esta
pertenencia de las islas pues para
quienes defienden que si las malvinas
deben ser argentinas pues los habitantes
de las islas son colonos que ocuparon
las islas pero las malvinas hoy en día
en el papel es uno de los 17 territorios
que están considerados por la onu como
colonizados y pese a que el comité de
descolonización de la onu ha llamado
varias veces en la historia a diálogos
entre los dos países el reino unido se
escuda en eso que usted dice en la
posición de la población a raíz de un
referendo que se convocó en 2013 y según
el cual 99 8% prácticamente toda la
población dijo que quería seguir siendo
británica usted cree que esto le quita
validez al reclamo argentino
esto no no sé si le quita validez al
reclamo argentino lo que sí le quita
factibilidad porque hay un punto que no
podemos desconocer
y es que la guerra la argentina la
perdió la guerra echó a perder
posibilidades mucho más concretas y
afianzadas que tenía la argentina por lo
menos desde la década de 1960 para poder
ejercer soberanía sobre batista había
incluso un nivel de aceptación por parte
de la población de origen británico en
las islas que tenían la categoría de
segunda dentro del estatus de ciudadanía
del imperio por el técnico donde
posiblemente la incorporación al
territorio nacional argentino podría
ofrecerles
una serie de ventajas y también hubo
distintas imaginaciones políticas
incluidas por parte de juan domingo
perón durante sus primeros gobiernos
para alguna forma de cogestión o de
administración como participada con la
población de las islas y con el gobierno
de reino unido y todo eso quedó
descartado
y poco antes de la guerra
argentina tenía una presencia fuerte
tanto a través de su empresa de envío de
combustibles como de una línea aérea
estatal como el envío de maestras para
enseñanza de idioma castellano
todo eso marcó un tremendo retroceso
entonces mi flash de hoy en esto quiero
insistir no es una posición oficial ni
de la universidad en la que trabajo ni
tampoco del organismo de investigación
es algo pertenezco me planteo es que a
40 años de la derrota de la guerra
debemos renovar el arsenal con el cual
el arsenal pacífico obviamente ahora
será el intelectual con el que pensamos
esta problemática desprovisto de toda
clase de ambigüedades porque si vamos no
tuve oportunidad de escuchar el discurso
del presidente pero sí leí las
declaraciones de días recientes este hay
un margen de ambigüedad por un lado se
está diciendo que la voluntad de
argentina es absolutamente pacífica pero
por el otro lado se plantea que nuestro
país no va a cejar reclamo entonces si
hay un ninguneo y un desconocimiento
fuerte de la población que debería ser
un actor a considerar y participe en
cualquier tipo de conversación